hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update and the latest news on far
cry 4 sources close to the project have
told Eurogamer that far cry 4 will be
released for xbox one playstation 4 and
pc in the first half of 2015 however we
don't currently know if xbox 360 and
playstation 3 versions are also in the
works far cry 4 will also swap out the
tropical setting of its predecessor for
the snowy mountains of the Himalayas
this marks a big switch and aesthetics
for the sandbox series which until now
has been set in sun drenched
environments it's rumored that players
will also be able to ride elephants and
there will be a variety of other new
features and additions to the title an
emphasis on hunting is still said to be
present and the world map will be split
up with outpost in a similar fashion to
Far Cry 3 Ubisoft executive Tony key
told GameSpot last year we're totally
site from Far Cry 3 it's a great brand
and now it's got the recognition it
deserves so we're clearly going to make
another one more on that soon far cry 4
will allegedly be unveiled at e3 2014
and we'll be covering that as it happens
right here on gamespot com